Today, I'm gonna take you to Pamukkale, a true wonder of planet Earth.
When you approach from a distance,...
...you might think Pamukkale is a snowy hill or even a glacier,...
...but look closer and you will notice a true wonder of Mother Nature.
Pamukkale's waters are rich in calcium carbonate,...
...making the floors of the pools as soft as cotton.
Actually, in Turkey, it's known as the "cotton castle."
It's not just another thermal spring; it's a geological marvel.
These mineral-rich waters are naturally heated to 36 Celsius.
From ancient times to modern days, people from around the world...
...have come to Pamukkale for its healing and therapeutic effects.